what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren and it looks like it is official
we reportedly have our Reed Richards aka
Mr Fantastic of our upcoming Fantastic
Four reboot taking place in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we might have
actually had him for a while but news
only just recently broke today that it
has been official and it looks like
Marvel Studios has plans to cast the
entire Fantastic Four team within a few
weeks if not a month from now to get
ready for a big Fantastic Four casting
announcement coming directly from Marvel
Studios very soon so we have our Mr
Fantastic it looks like we might have
our Sue storm and our Ben Grim aka the
thing and Johnny Storm should be coming
up next as well so we'll talk about the
entire cast of The Fantastic Four today
and when to expect that announcement
coming from Marvel Studios and if you're
a fan of Marvel be sure to subscribe to
the the channel so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos and news and
don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment to enter our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items as well winner gets to pick and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
so I've heard some mixed reviews about
the choice for this specific actor to
play Reed Richards and it looks like
we're going to continue to hear some of
it as some fans may be really happy and
some fans not so much but it does appear
that Adam Driver has been officially
cast by Marvel Studios to play Reed
Richards aka Mr Fantastic now the rumor
about this got out kind of a few months
ago it's actually been out for a little
bit now I believe it was Grace Randolph
who first said that Marvel Studios was
looking at a certain Star Wars actor to
jump over to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to play Mr Fantastic and a lot
of people kind of assumed John boyega
some people were stating that Marvel
Studios probably wants a person of color
to play Reed Richards and it does indeed
look like Marvel Studios does want a
person of color to play one of the roles
in the Fantastic Four just not read
Richards but we'll get into that in just
a second now no actor was specifically
mentioned but of course Adam driver's
name was thrown in there and then some
insiders came out and said that Adam
Driver has met with Marvel Studios about
the role for Mr Fantastic then it was
stated that he had the offer to play the
role but we didn't know if he had
accepted it or not however this morning
The Insider account my time to shine
hello who has an excellent track record
with these things and Scoops has
confirmed this by tweeting out this
morning it's done Adam Driver is our
read Richards so we have a lot more to
talk about but right away let me know
what you think about this casting in the
comments down below like I said I've
seen a bunch of mixed reactions people
saying like I think this is great some
people saying like I don't see it at all
I can't see him as Mr Fantastic I'm
definitely willing to give them a chance
I do like Adam Driver a lot and I think
that he has a lot of range as an actor
plus with Star Wars he was a part of
Disney same thing with Marvel they're
both owned by Disney so he's already
Disney family which means that Marvel
Studios and Disney probably like him so
this doesn't come as that big of a
surprise but what might come as a little
bit of a surprise to some people is who
right now is reportedly going to play
the thing or is at least in talks with
Marvel Studios to play Ben Grimm
according to Jeff Snyder on the hot mic
podcast he recently said that he
believes that a person of color will
play one of the members of the Fantastic
Four and that member could possibly be
Ben Grimm aka the thing and he said on
the podcast that a possible Contender
for this role could be Hamilton star
David Diggs and it also happens to be
that David Diggs is half Jewish and it
has been said that Marvel Studios and
Disney does want an actor that is part
Jewish to play the thing since he is
Jewish in the comics now ultimately
Marvel Studios doing a person of color
for Grimm doesn't really come down to
the color since they're going to be the
thing the entire time in fact based off
of some reports we know that Ben Grimm
is already going to be the thing in the
Fantastic Four film so we might not even
see him in human form maybe some
flashbacks but based off of what we know
about this Kevin feige already said hey
this isn't a true origin story for the
Fantastic Four and some reports from
insiders told us that they're going to
be the Fantastic Four team already when
we meet them in the MCU for the first
time in their film in fact some reports
state that they're already going to be
parents so well into being the Fantastic
Four so the thing could be played by
really anybody in fact there was a
report out there stating that Mila Kunis
actually might have been in the run to
play the thing herself which I'm glad is
not happening at least our fingers are
crossed that it's not happening but
ultimately it's going to come down to
the talent of the actor actress that is
inside that suit or doing the mocap for
the thing and David Diggs has some
serious acting chops and I think a lot
of people would like to see him play a
role in The Fantastic Four as the thing
now this is less official about the news
about Adam Driver Adam Driver is Mr
Fantastic according to my time to shine
hello that is official we are just
waiting from an announcement from Marvel
Studios and this casting for David Diggs
as the thing is pretty much just a rumor
at this point but the other contenders
to play the thing in the MCU that we've
heard of in recent are Seth Rogen and
Jason Segal we've talked about reasons
why they both would be good they both
have comedic backgrounds they're both
hilarious and they both have of course
experience acting in very serious roles
as well which both are needed for the
thing because oftentimes he does provide
that comedic relief right now I think my
choice would be Jason Segal but hey let
me know your thoughts about the casting
for the thing in the comments down below
would you like the V digs to play the
thing or do you have somebody else in
your mind who you'd like to see now as
far as Sue's storm of the Fantastic Four
is concerned we've recently heard that
Margot Robbie widely known for playing
the character Harley Quinn over in the
DC Universe has been given the offer to
play Sue storm in the MCU by Marvel
Studios we have not heard if she has
accepted that offer yet but apparently
she is the top Contender to play Sue
storm in the MCU that's who they want
now the other big names that we've heard
to possibly play Sue storm that Marvel
Studios might want are Vanessa Kirby who
I would personally love to see play Sue
storm in the MCU Mila Kunis although she
has denied being involved in the
Fantastic Four in any way but says that
she knows who has been cast and of
course Jody Comer and I would love to
see her play Sue storm as well but
honestly I think Margot Robbie could do
a really great job as well if I could
see past Harley Quinn which I think we
could easily do once she appears in the
Fantastic Four outfit but hey same thing
let us know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below now as far as
Johnny Storm is concerned we haven't
really heard much around this casting
what we heard recently was that Paul
Muska was in the running to play Johnny
Storm AKA The Human Torch however it
looks like he passed just on playing
that role so the role for Johnny storm
is pretty much out there in the open now
and we haven't heard anything about any
actors meeting with Marvel Studios to
play this role but it looks like they're
going to have to cast them pretty soon
like I mentioned in the beginning of the
video Marvel Studios looks to be
planning a big announcement for the cast
of The Fantastic Four and it looks like
this is going to happen possibly but not
yet confirmed but possibly at San Diego
Comic-Con which is only a couple of
months away it's coming in July July
19th is when it starts Marvel Studios is
known for its huge Hall age panels where
they reveal a lot typically and the last
two Comic Cons Kevin feige did talk
about the Fantastic Four the one in 2019
at the very end he said we didn't even
have time to talk about the Fantastic
Four then in 2022 San Diego Comic-Con he
gave us an official release date for The
Fantastic Four in phase six now this San
Diego Comic-Con we are expecting a
casting announcement a lot of inside
letter said that this is what they're
looking for and the cast for The
Fantastic Four is pretty much being
finalized within the next few weeks most
likely because they do want to announce
it at San Diego Comic-Con so we should
have an official cast very very soon but
as of right now it does look like we
officially have our Mr Fantastic Reed
Richards the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and that is Adam Driver let me know all
of your thoughts about this in the
comments down below do you like it do
you not like it do you love it do you
hate it let us know don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
so you can enter our giveaway as well
you can always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf
foreign